we are learning more about the inner
workings of facebook as revealed in a
massive trove of leaked documents cbs
news along with other outlets reviewed
thousands of pages of internal research
employee comments and presentations and
altogether they suggest that facebook
knew its platforms facebook instagram
whatsapp can fuel hate polarization
conspiracy theories and misinformation
but at times did little to stop it 60
minutes plus correspondent lori siegel
is here with the story lori good morning
to you they went through a lot of
documents here what'd you learn
good morning guys and facebook
whistleblower francis haugen left the
company earlier this year after
photographing thousands of pages of
documents the wall street journal first
reported on some of them and now
redacted copies have been shared by a
congressional source with journalists
around the world while the company says
there's no way to draw fair conclusions
from the quote curated selection we sat
down with one former executive who says
the documents reflect his own experience
from what was going on inside facebook
i became convinced that facebook was
causing harm in the world and causing
division in the world brian bolen spent
11 years building facebook most recently
overseeing market and product strategy
he left last year when he says he saw
the platform driving racism after george
floyd's death if i couldn't change it
and i tried and i couldn't change it and
that i couldn't be a part of it you
believe that it was tearing us apart
yeah and i'm concerned that facebook
causes divisions in a lot of areas
political being one of them and a
powerful one that we feel viscerally but
also in race and ethnicity religion
evidence of those concerns can be found
across the thousands of pages of leaked
internal records from inside the company
they provide an intimate window into
facebook's own research and the
frustrations of employees who were
trying to clean up the site we shared
some of them with bowlin these people
are phd level researchers creating
documents that are highlighting real
harms on the platform like this research
that reveals the company new vaccine
hesitancy was rampant in comments this
analysis found facebook systems missed
most of the hate speech on the platform
in afghanistan detecting it at a
worryingly low rate and this one from
july 2019 called carroll's journey into
q anon charts how a dummy account could
be served up conspiracy theories in just
two days some of this research showed
that within a week of someone just
liking a conservative account like
melania trump or donald trump they were
served up q anon content when i saw a
lot of this stuff it was enough for me
to leave the company there wasn't enough
focus on taking a research study like
that and saying shouldn't we invest a
lot of time and effort in really
understanding that the report
recommended facebook's stopped
suggesting q on content to users but it
wasn't until more than a year later that
the company banned the group it seemed
like oftentimes these changes weren't
implemented
why not because those types of safety
things are not the top priority the top
priority's growth it's the same
allegation frances haugen made when she
revealed her identity on 60 minutes
earlier this month facebook over and
over again has shown it uses profit over
safety and a claim facebook ceo mark
zuckerberg denied
writing in a post two days later this
idea we prioritize profit over safety
and well-being that's just not true but
according to one memo from last year
zuckerberg told employees they would not
move ahead with part of this proposal to
reduce bad content if the changes led to
a material trade-off in meaningful
social interactions facebook's term for
user engagement mark chose to stick with
the growth side of the business it's a
stark example of a trade-off between do
you want to reduce harmful content do
you want to reduce people's time on the
platform you choose keeping people's
time on the platform a resignation
letter posted last year from a rank and
file employee says the cold shoulder
from top management was demoralizing
integrity teams are facing increasing
barriers to building safeguards we were
willing to act only after things had
spiraled into a dire state do you think
that this is a fair characterization
it's a very fair characterization if you
look at the history of facebook they
clean up the mess after the fact
[Applause]
and there may have been no bigger mess
than the january 6 attack on the u.s
capitol according to this document
safety measures put in place ahead of
the election were rolled back and only
reintroduced after the riot broke out
internally frustration boiled over one
employee wrote haven't we had enough
time to figure out how to manage
discourse without enabling violence it
felt like the people who were closest to
understanding the work and closest to
understanding the problem were the ones
most frustrated in a statement a
facebook spokesperson told cbs news the
leaked pages lack context and leave an
incomplete distorted picture of our
company there's this very strong story
being told that these documents are
cherry-picked and i can tell you as
somebody who's been there that's just
not true you are part of these products
you helped build these products you
probably made millions why should we
listen to you i don't benefit from
speaking up negatively against former
friends and co-workers there are real
harms being caused to real human beings
and at the end of the day you can decide
whether you want to listen to me or you
can look at a bunch of documents that
were written by some of the most
talented people in the world that are
saying the same things virtual reality
bolan is sounding the alarm as the
company is pouring millions into an
ambitious plan to move beyond social
media and develop its own virtual world
a facebook metaverse we're entering a
new era of the web it's in these virtual
worlds where our children will live and
they will have their identities should
we trust the company no you shouldn't
and you should be terrified because if
the company is going to build a new
metaverse but is going to have safety
security protecting against
misinformation and hate speech
is a relatively low priority what world
is that going to be
facebook says it's invested millions in
developing these new products
responsibly the company declined to make
ceo mark zuckerberg available for an
interview but said in a statement we're
a business and we make profit but the
idea that we do so at the expense of
people's safety or well-being
misunderstands where our own commercial
interests lie
these facebook papers are now part of
several whistle whistleblower complaints
francis haugen filed with federal
officials such an interesting bit of
reporting there facebook saying oh these
are cherry-picked and the whistleblowers
are saying oh it's a whole field of
cherries it's nothing but cherries right
pick anyone uh brian boland uh the
executive who came forward to you he's
criticizing the company does he have a
prescription for fixing things
yeah i mean i think that's important he
says more accountability and he goes to
this conversation about regulation we've
all had this conversation before he says
regulators need to create an oversight
body to talk about transparency and you
know we've spent the last weeks looking
through so much of this research and
there were thousands of pages of
research and by the way we should
mention facebook did this research about
its own company and what he said was you
know there should be a safe way for this
research to go to other researchers and
people to share this so we can all have
a better understanding of what happens
on these social media platforms if
there's a way to do so and respect
people's privacy so i think that's a
place to start and by the way all of
this is important to say that this is
coming at a time where facebook is
reportedly rebranding to be a metaverse
company
and you know you might not have heard
the word metaverse yet but you will and
your children will because this is this
next iteration of the internet and so
we've got to start talking about safety
there yeah wow
it's a lot i wonder if the information
we now have too will impact how we use
our devices right you know now that we
have the information are we going to be
more intentional as a group as humans
and not allowing these devices to
control us lori thank you so much